hey guys today it is the 31st of August
my name's Jess McDonald and here's what
mattered in gaming today uncharted water
seeps and finally has a release date as
an else twice only today the game will
land in North America on much 18 of next
year so pencil that one in if you're
keen on top of the release date news
sony also revealed two limited edition
versions of the game the $80 special
edition contains the game a steelbook
case designed by alexander eh arena and
art book a sticker sheet because that's
a thing grown adults need and a pack of
in-game currency for spending on various
multiplayer content if you shell out
another forty dollars on top of that you
can get the lib italia collector's
edition which also includes a 12-inch
nathan drake statue 3 multiplayer
outfits to weapon skins madagascar
sidekick outfit and a henry every search
of ball cap there's also a digital
deluxe edition priced of eighty dollars
from the PlayStation Store which
includes the uncharted 4 triple pack
that will grant you access to the first
story add-on and through multiplayer
packs which will unlock rare items the
mystery around Metal Gear Solid Vybz
microtransactions if getting a little
clearer today thanks to an image posted
to fansite Metal Gear Network the image
displays the pricing details for mother
based coins which you can use to
activate the Phantom Pain's Forward
Operating Base online PvP mode mother
base coins appear to be used to speed up
gameplay as is generally the case with
these things so instead of potentially
waiting an hour for activities to happen
on your base you can instantly speed up
time by paying the pricing for these mb
coins ranges from one dollar sixty-five
of your real world money for 100 coins
to 6,000 mb coins for seventy nine
dollars 95 in other not so cool metal
gear news the gorgeous special edition
metal gear solid 5 ps4 has a typo
fortunately it's not on the playstation
or diamond dog
but but for a fictitious caution message
that states do not use millennium
lubrication it's a nit picking era but
the chemicals name should read
molybdenum miley microsoft have
announced an Xbox one elite bundle that
contains a console which should load
your games up twenty percent faster the
bundle contains an Xbox one which
includes a one terabyte solid state
hybrid hard drive as well as the new
elect controller according to Microsoft
of the new SSD stores frequently
accessed files on a solid-state
partition and optimizes system
performance so you can get to the action
up to twenty percent I'll start from
energy saving mode the Xbox one elite
bundle will launch in November for 500
bucks while the elite controller alone
will sell for a hundred and fifty
microsoft also announced a new lunar
white version of the standard xbox one
controller which is said to have
improved grip texture on top of its
smoking new golden white Palestine let
me know down in back comment box what
you think of the Xbox one elite to
bundle and if you keen on picking it up
you can add a game spot we've got news
on a fallout 4 Xbox one and the release
date for deus ex mankind divided that is
all the good stuff I have for you today
be sure to let me know what mattered to
you and I will catch you same time
tomorrow
you